my name is Rothstein Salazar a and I'm  from Ann Arbor Michigan i graduated from  wash not christian academy in 2010 and  i'm a politics major at Hillsdale  College the spring I'm interning in  united states senator Deb Fischer office  as part of the Washington Hillsdale  internship program the Washington  Hillsdale internship program we call  whip for short we bring anywhere between  10 to 20 students a semester out to DC  they take two or three classes and they  in turn on the hill at the Heritage  Foundation really anywhere they want to  we find somebody coming out of college  who has some practical real-world  experience especially experience that  applies to what we do it really sets  them apart Washington is one of those  places that kids can learn a lot and  gain a lot just from being here for a  few months and that sense coming here  and having that internship experience i  can guarantee will be life-changing  you